[Musique]
je leur ai fait une espèce assez rare de
flâneurs choisit parfois l'anachronique
bateau mouche pour essayer de retrouver
la lenteur de vivre d'autres
représentants de cette race en voie de
disparition il était par les travaux
forcés choisissent le dimanche pour se
livrer à leurs coupables badri en effet
le flâneur et distrait il est si occupés
à ne rien faire ce gobemouche ce poète
c'est un génie que ses rêveries le livre
sans défense aux injures des
automobilistes aux sarcasmes des
cyclistes oblath femmes des
motocyclistes et aux derniers outrages
des agents de la circulation le dimanche
paris appartient à l'inoffensif rôdeur
jean veil paresseuse avec un instinct
pour et sur le parfait flâneur parisien
dédaigne les sites seront connus et
préfère la petite histoire à la grande
quand il va jusqu'au bout je n'ai pas
pour admirer les canotiers qui vont
découvrir les rivages du temps durement
pas du tout c'est pour les rêver à
l'ombre d'un arbre du pré catelan
reîtres pourpoint qu'angers paraît-il de
plus de cent soixante cinq ans la
pourpre est garanti monte on comprend
pourquoi elle les grands de ce monde est
menaçant vêtir pour impressionner les
badauds qui les acclament mais voyons un
peu deux cent soixante cinq ans
ce être majestueux elles ont été
plantées en 1789 la cour royale était
pourtant mal vu cette année là passons
pas se réfugiant nous en des temps plus
anciens les démolitions successives ont
rejeté ce vieux puits du 12e siècle hors
de l'église saint julien le pauvre et à
l'intérieur du square rené viviani
politiciens célèbre est déjà oubliée
voici le patriarche l'ancêtre des arbres
de paris les marronniers de nos square
doivent le respect à ce faux acacia à
son âge il pourrait être le vrai que ce
serait la moindre des choses est ce pas
le botaniste robin la plante est là en
1601 et modestement l'a baptisé le
robinier le nom lui est resté pour
éviter tout calcul mental aux curieux
qui peuvent se trouver dans la salle le
précisons que ce robuste gaillard frise
ses 350 ans comme certains hommes
politiques qui n'ont pourtant pas encore
atteint son âge ce doyen s'appuie sur
une béquille admirez maintenant si le
coeur vous en billets puisque vous êtes
là pour ça après tout le frère cadet de
notre leader
un acacia tout aussi faux que le
précédent d'ailleurs nous planter au
jardin des plantes en 1636 par vespasien
robin fils de son père
c'est une histoire de galopins le vrai
flâneur évite les marches forcées
le resto non au jardin des plantes pour
lire un petit bonjour à ce cèdre
rapporté du liban en 1734 par bernard de
jussieu dans son chapeau paraît-il et le
botaniste se priver en chemin de sa
ration d'eau pour arroser son petit
protégé
en réalité c'est un médecin anglais
collinson qui lui avait donné quelques
graines beaucoup plus facile à
transporter perfide albion
toujours au jardin des plantes que ça
doit être le nom qui veut ça voici la
coupe du séquoia bimillénaire le slameur
adore acquérir de nouvelles
connaissances en baguenaudant jeu ces
plaques de cuivre lui indique avec le
développement de l'arbre la date de la
naissance du christ l'invasion d'attila
précurseur et diverses autres aux
événements historiques jusqu'à la guerre
hispano-américaine n'est pas du bois
dont on fait des chutes mais de
l'histoire avec une grande lâche cette
ville du séquoia nous a été offerte
amicalement et dans un bus instructif
par l'american légion
[Musique]
à l'orée du bois de chaville où je me
suis laissé dire qu'on cueille un si
joli médias voilà un thème qui fleurit
depuis six ans printemps ce qui ne
rajeunit pas 3 rue volta la plus vieille
maison de paris elle comptait les plus
de 700 hiver
un timide élèves de monsieur le
corbusier à moderniser sa boutique de
droite
par contre l'épicerie fruiterie de
gauche n'a pas encore souffert de ses
bienfaits ce ne sont pas ses quelques
voitures de flâneurs motorisés qui nous
des taux longs de la demeure d'un
connétable bardé de vieilles pierres le
cir olivier de clisson étaient logés 58
rue de leur siège comme vous et moi
juste à côté 20 rue etienne marcel jean
sans peur
autre personnage à côte de maille a fait
mentir cette tour en 1090 par économie
sans doute elle est étalée aussi à
l'enceinte de philippe auguste ce cas
précis à célèbre avait entouré paris de
ses fortifications pour l'empêcher de se
tendre démesurément
voici le tracé de ses murailles sur un
plan du paris actuel est ce qu il en
reste sept cent cinquante ans après que
nous ayons eu la douleur de perdre
philippe au mieux les morts vont vite
mais à l'intérieur du crédit municipal
55 rue des francs-bourgeois ma tante
très familiale a conservé l'empreinte de
la muraille qui traversait ses cours et
même une ancienne tour de guet sera ne
vois tu rien à venir si un prêteur 3 rue
clovis ou quelques vestiges en parfait
état de conservation
les monuments historiques ont sûrement
dû passer par la passage du commerce
saint-andré à l'intérieur d'un atelier
de serrurerie une autre tour de guet ne
sert plus qu'à accrocher des outils
cette utilisation intime d'un ouvrage de
défense n'avait pas été prévu par les
stratèges du bon roi philippe auguste
le fameux rem les quais de la seine et
les bouquinistes ou l'amateur avisé peut
encore espérer trouver une édition
originale des oeuvres complètes de
monsieur cécile salorges tandis qu'on
transmet mazarine l'hôtel des pompes
construit en 1723 par monsieur dumouriez
dupérier depuis la première caserne de
pompiers mais caroline chérie fut-elle
amoureuse d'un sapeur il lui sera
beaucoup pardonné car elle a beaucoup
paix mais c'est tout comme mademoiselle
louise de la vallière et qui un beau
matin de l'an de grâce 1674 franchi le
seuil du carmel de l'incarnation pour y
vivre et y mourir que aujourd'hui au 284
rue saint jacques
l'ombre de la douce boiteuse
trébucherait sur la voiture à bras et
les réserves de charbon d'un bouillant
installé sous le même porsche
il fut un temps les moineaux de paris
vivait heureux
pourtant ce ne sont pas eux qui par
souscription publique ont fait élever ce
monument à leur meilleur ami dans la
cour des anciennes écuries qui jadis
abritait les foules post à la diligence
les mini bus le tramway auteuil saint
sulpice maintenant il n'y a que le
maigre crottin des allées cavalières
pauvre moineaux et au 67 rue pigalle ce
sont des chevaux vapeur qui sont
enfermés dans les écuries devenu garage
l'abreuvoir n'est plus que fontaine pour
radiateur assoiffés
mais quelle carrosse ou quelle voiture
pourrait s'engager dans la rue du chat
qui pêche la plus étroite de paris ces
deux délicieux bambins ne seront pas
victimes d'un accident de circulation en
jouant au grand air si on peut dire
avant de rentrer chez eux dans le plus
petit immeuble parisien qui ornent la
rue du château d'eau de sa somptueuse
façade large d'un mètre
les gros clients de cet horloger doivent
tenter de profil dans son échoppe car un
maître queux dépens d'arles
tiens à propos monsieur voulez-vous vous
reculé d'1 m
[Musique]
merci bien vous nous révéler ainsi un
mètre étalon incrusté là sur la façade
du ministère de la justice
en 1848 et sans doute pour mesurer les
rigueurs de la loi en traversant la
place vendôme
n'oubliez pas de vérifier avant d'aller
examiner une plaque quelle hauteur du
230 rue de rivoli un bon souvenir après
tant d'autres
celui d'une république la première du
nom tu n'as quitte ici comme par hasard
bel enfant de nombreux pères en voici un
autre de souvenirs historiques
la colonne de juillet nous permet de
constater que la fameuse bastille ne
s'élevait pas au milieu de la place du
même nom
vous voyez d'ici l'épreuve et de
couleurs qui marquent l'emplacement de
ses quatre tours arrière entre la rue
saint-antoine et le boulevard henri iv
regardez bien nous faisons apparaître la
vieille forteresse en chair et en os à
sa vraie place restait à l'aide d'une
maquette qui sommeille encore au musée
carnavalet
les bons esprits que rassure encore la
démolition symbolique de la bastille
peuvent se recueillir square henri galy
devant quelques pierres venant des
fondations de la dernière prison ou bien
à l'intérieur du métro bastille ou bien
encore s'ils le préfèrent devant ce
petit chef-d'oeuvre sculpté dans l'une
des pierres de la forteresse
c'est l'entrepreneur palois qui après
avoir démoli la bastille fille sculpter
ses ex voto l'année suivante il
regrettait peut-être son geste
inconsidéré une bonne prise on a
toujours une espèce d'utilité permanente
dans les pays libres et le valide
déjà non non non ne craignez rien de ses
canons braqués vers le grand et petit
palais ne tireront pas dommage
d'ailleurs car ces édifices mais riche
pire et nous avons horreur de la
violence et de peur du gendarme
nous vous les montres ont simplement
pour vous à mener par le bout de votre
mix la mer jusqu'à une autre bouches à
feu
celle qui dans les jardins du palais
royal tenait d'abord juste derrière la
statue de 1786 à 1914 a tonné midi pour
les parisiens nous avons renouvelé ce
rite pour nous après avoir obtenu toutes
les autorisations nécessaires attendu le
soleil pendant de longues journées
pluvieuses supporter les plaisanteries
de vos frères badauds étaient enfin
après tant d'années de silence voici le
coup de midi du 15 juin 1954
voilà une date historique de plus depuis
sous les fenêtres ne brille plus le
fanal bleus de madame colette le petit
canot est resté silencieux
mais à l'intérieur de l'église saint
sulpice un curieuse à pareille date en
2007 144 permettaient aux fidèles à un
peu distraite de déterminer les dates
des fêtes religieuses
[Musique]
vous voyez c'est très simple un rayon
lumineux vient frapper cette ligne de
cuivre et des repères permettent aux
paroissiens d'établir le programme des
réjouissances un soleil ne se montre pas
aux mondieux ils consultent leur
calendrier habituel
ainsi ne sont ils jamais pris au
dépourvu il ya aussi un cadran solaire
qui est des orfèvres
par beau temps il avoue enfin ils
avouent leur à ces messieurs de la pj
l'horloge du palais de justice passe
pour être la première horloge publique
de paris elle donne l'heure juste
l'heure officielle celle que l'on peut
discuter sans encourir les rigueurs de
la loi
elle varie avec elle d'ailleurs et nul
ne s'en étonne pas nul ne s'en étonne
sauf les fleurs qui sur les pentes d'un
montmartre pas encore désaffectée de ses
chansons et de ces lignes le monde
jusqu'à la rue de l'abreuvoir pour y
demander leur qui retarde sur son siècle
à ce cadran solaire surmonté d'un code
qui n'a pas les ergots du fameux coq
gaulois mais le bon bec montmartrois son
cocorico joyeux réveillera-t-il les
moulins endormi atteindra-t-il celui de
longchamp où l'on encourage la race
chevaline celui du cimetière
montparnasse réfugiés parmi les tombes
ces survivants du joyeux troupeau aux
ailes battantes qui attendaient leur don
quichotte quotidien
le but fut leurs adeptes ces deux
moulins émigrèrent rue lepic au xviiie
siècle l'un venant du quartier de
l'opéra l'autre de montrouge
car le dernier moulin de la butte a été
arraché à sa terre natale le 17 décembre
1911 la légende de cette estampe affirme
le vieux paris qui s'en va et oui
beaucoup de choses sont parties avec ce
vieux phare il a par exemple le
propriétaire de ce moulin souvenirs
dresser sur sa tombe au fond du vieux
cimetière de montmartre où vers une fois
l'an le jour de la toussaint est adossée
à l'église saint pierre
non non l'église saint pierre n'est pas
la plus ancienne de la capitale ni
saint-martin-des-champs d'ailleurs voyez
moi si vous voulez mais la laisse le
transept et la tour romane de saint
germain des prés deux dames en l'an 1000
une année où ses paroissiens terrorisé
par de funestes prédictions vivaient
déjà dans les caves la moue devant saint
germain l'auxerrois levant le nez
versons aux porches unique à paris
assure l'agent scook et vers son clocher
historique bien entendu vous entendez
cette cloche du 24 août 15 172 celle de
la saint barthélemy c'est la même classe
qui sonne pour vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et celle-ci des eaux du lanternon du
palais de justice lui fait écho comme
cette nuit là
[Musique]
mais heureusement l'église sait aussi se
montrer miséricordieuse c'est ainsi
qu'elle fait planter des ormes tel celui
fameux de l'église saint gervais pour
embraser les amoureux victime d'un lapin
non atteints de myxomatose mais c'est
une info tu n'es pas le seul à attendre
sous l'homme qui sait
[Musique]
évidemment la disgrâce de ton ancêtres à
la blouse maraîchère ne consolera penta
jolie cravate de sa déception
bon une de perdue dix a retrouvé soûl
ormes bien entendu comme son nom l
indique le pont neuf est le plus vieux
paul paris cette série 3 qui suivant une
coutume qui s'est perpétuée jusqu'à à
travers les actualités
cinématographiques en posant la première
pierre il fut achevée en 1604 sous le
bon roi henri qui nous donna dont la
poule au pur il pour neuf tous les
dimanches étant le fils est tout aussi
nouveau car pour la première fois un
pont ne supportait pas de maison comme
le pont notre dame que voici
jusqu'à la création du pont-neuf ont
traversé le fleuve sans même la
percevoir ce qui était très gênant pour
le tourisme et ses fleurs
forte heureusement voici les choses en
ordre le pont-neuf était paraît-il un
endroit agréable où l'on était sur le
rencontrer à toute heure du jour ou de
la nuit
un moine cheval blanc et une fille
public qui pour la première fois à paris
exercer le plus vieux métier du monde
sur un trottoir autres nouveaux titres
de l'époque il en est hélas plus de même
aujourd'hui pour ces heureux de
rencontre bien que ce soir henri iii qui
lui posait la première pierre ce
monarque étant de mauvaises moeurs n'eût
pas droit à cette jolie statue dorée cap
qui fut d'ailleurs fondu en 1792 par
quelques descendants ravaillac
mais le bon roi henri devait avoir sa
revanche de 25 à août 1810 lui les 40
bus transportant sa nouvelle statue
s'étant tard et exténuée place bon vous
2000 citoyens de toutes classes et
amateurs de poule au pot sera dit
certain panache blanc légendaire et
remplaçant les bêtes à cornes amenèrent
la statue jusqu'à son socle essuyant une
larme provoqué par le bon geste de ses
fleurs au risque n'a rien perdu de son
charme
fini le vert-galant de son échec c'est
un square aquatique le 14 juillet jour
anniversaire de la prise de la bastille
dont le goût parlions tout honneur on
étire le feu d'artifice des liesses
populaires les eaux paisibles du fleuve
reflète les belles bleues les belles
rouges la belle verte et la splendeur
tholance du bouquet mais dès le
lendemain las elle retrouve ses amis
les pêcheurs à la ligne ces amoureux
c'est un du dimanche bien entendu son
bateau mouche admirer dans le haut de
l'écran à gauche l'authentic bouchon
d'un pêcheur distress son wars qui
surveille les crues et leur demande le
mot de passe secte et à la majestueuse
douceur et cette dame en forme de
réverbères géant
oui la france a offert à l'amérique une
immense statue de la liberté
les parisiens émigrés là bas nous allons
retour de liberté j'ai beaucoup d'amour
que paris révèle sa beauté encore
faut-il prendre le temps de l'aimer
[Musique]